GONNA MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE DEVELOP
TO CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE THAT MAY BE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE COBIT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIRES. OUR
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. A COUPLE OF
TIMES ODD THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. AND
AGAIN WE'LL PUT THAT UP THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF TIMES GOING
FORWARD. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LAN AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
INDEED ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OUR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOLS SO AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE-
BECAUSE WE DO WANT EVERYONE TO
BE HEARD. AND FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF OUR STENOGRAPHER AINA. I
WILL ASK ALL SPEAKERS
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES ALIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY.
AND I HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO ASK
PEOPLE TO START AGAIN SLOW
DOWN- AND SO I BEG YOUR
INDULGENCE IF I HAVE TO DO THAT
IT IS ONLY BECAUSE- WE WANT TO
GET YOUR TESTIMONY AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. OUR OUR
HARDWORKING STENOGRAPHER IS
ABLE TO DO THAT. SO BEFORE WE
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES WILL
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME THAT WE VOTE. SO WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH HI OUR
PRESENT GROWTH PRESENTS. HE
AND WATER YOUR MOTHER HERE
LAYARD YOU'RE WEIRD HERE BATES
HERE. HERE ATKINS YOU'RE
TALKING. OKAY I AM GOING TO
ESTABLISH A GET SOME OF THE
WORK OUT OF THE WAY VIA MOTIONS
FROM MEMBERS AND I WILL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SEPARATE THAT
MOTION SO I WOULD ASK FOR. A
SINGLE MOTION ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEM TO BE ANTONIO F.
BENJAMIN MEMBER OF THE HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
I WOULD SO MOVE THANK YOU
SENATOR A MOTION HAS BEEN MADE
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE I GREW UP
I KAMLAGER I LONGER I LAYERED
AYE BATES. I'M STAN FAITH
ABSTAINED. ALCON FIVE CONCISE.
AND I WOULD. PLEASE I WOULD
MOVE TO SEE OKAY THANK YOU- THE
SECRETARY HAS THE VOTE ON TO BE
A SENATOR LAYERED MOVES ITEM TO
SEE FRANCISCO J. SILVA MEMBER
ALSO THE HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE. ROVAK STAIN KAMLAGER I
LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE I. HATE
ABSTAINED IT'S ABSTAINED ATKINS
FIVE CONCERNED SO THAT IS THREE
TWO ZERO- IF IT IS OKAY I'D BE
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE AND FOUR
TOGETHER UNLESS MEMBERS HAVE
CONCERNS THAT IS ITEM THREE IS
THE REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES ITEM FOUR IS A WORK
RULE WAIVER REQUEST FROM
SENATOR RALPH HERE OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THE WAY JOINT RULE
SIXTY TO EIGHTY HERE THE SUNSET
REVIEW OF OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA ON FRIDAY
APRIL NINTH. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITHOUT. SUFFICIENT NOTICE.
EVERYBODY OKAY WITH THAT THANK
YOU SENATOR BREAUX HAS MADE A
MOTION. AND SECRETARY WE CALL
THE ROLL GROWTH. I KAMLAGER I
LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE. AYE
EIGHTH AYE I CAN I CAN SIGN
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FIVE TWO ZERO AND
WITH THAT I AND WITH GREAT
THANKS FOR ALL THIS APPOINTEES
PATIENTS AS WE GOT UP AND
RUNNING TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO
TURN THE ITEM ONE A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
MISTER OR MONDO M. QUINN TERO
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION SO LET ME
WELCOME YOU DIRECTOR. OUR
OFFER- INVITE YOU TO. INTRODUCE
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE. AND THEN AFTER THAT WE
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT LET ME
JUST SAY WELCOME AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I'M JOINED BY MY WIFE
BRIDGET BREEN AND OUR DAUGHTERS
LILY MORAINE AND ISABELLA LUNA.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
DANA POINTED DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK SYSTEM IS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST HONORS IN MY
LIFE. MY PASSIONS FOR NATURE
PARKS AND WILDLIFE FOR LIFELONG
INTEREST THAT HAVE GUIDED MY
CAREER. I'VE SERVED AS U. S.
NATIONAL PARK RANGER AND I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MERCED. I ALSO SERVED AS A AN
ELECTED WATER DISTRICT DIRECTOR
AND AS AN APPOINTEE ON THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
THEY BELIEVE THE DIVERSITY OF
THESE EXPRIENCES ARE HELPING
TO INFORM ME AS I LEAVE THE
DEPARTMENT FORWARD. SEEKING
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOLUTIONS FOR
PARKS AND FOR PEOPLE. AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THIS GREAT STATE
PARK SYSTEM. IN THIS TIME OF
COLLUDED DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
AND SOCIAL UNREST. PARKS BECAME
REFUGE IN PLACES OF RELAXATION
AND RESPITE FOR THE PUBLIC.
THIS IS SO SHOWN US CLEARLY
THAT PARKS FOR THE PUBLIC ARE
ESSENTIAL LANDSCAPES AND THE
CENTRAL WATER SCAPES. AND STATE
PARKS WE KNOW WE MUST BRING THE
BEST OF OURSELVES FORWARD AND
TOGETHER WITH THE PUBLIC AND
ALL OF OUR PART PARTNERS. WE
NEED TO REMAIN FOCUSED ON THE
CRITICAL PRIORITIES FOR PARKS
AND FOR PEOPLE. AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION I WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR ACTIONS INCLUDE
IMPLEMENTING MANAGEMENT
PLANNING AND DESIGN. TO MAKE
PARKS MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
RESILIENT WELL INTO THE FUTURE.
OUR ACTIONS AND DECISIONS WILL
INCLUDE CLIMATE CHANGE PLANNING
AN ADAPTATION. WE WILL APPLY
JUSTICE EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IN ALL ASPECTS OF
PARK MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS AND
DECISION MAKING. WE WILL MEET
THE DEMAND FOR PARKS FOR ALL BY
PURSUING NEW PARKLAND
ACQUISITIONS AND INVESTING
GRANTS IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. I BELIEVE THAT
DEVELOPING STRONG PARK LEADERS
AND TEAMS FOR THIS ENTRY IS AN
IMPERATIVE FOR OUR SUCCESS
OVERALL INCLUSIVE OF THESE
ABOVE THESE GOALS PARKS WILL
CONTINUE TO CREATE A MORE
EFFICIENT PARKS ORGANIZATION
AND THIS PATH FORWARD IS
REFLECTED IN OUR FIVE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN. WHICH WE WILL
BE PUBLISHING LATER THIS YEAR.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
EMPLOYEES STAKEHOLDERS PARTNERS
THE PUBLIC AND ELECTED LEADERS
TO REFINE AND IMPLEMENT THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS AS WE SHAPE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK SYSTEM.
FOR A HEALTHY FUTURE FUTURE
WELL INTO THIS CENTURY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
PRIVILEGE TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND START WITH SENATOR LAYERED
GO AHEAD SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER. THEN A MR
DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND FOR YOUR SERVICE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE MEETING
THAT- WE HAD- YESTERDAY IT WAS
REALLY HELPFUL. AND I KNOW WE
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER. IN YOUR
PRIOR INCARNATIONS AS WATER
COMMISSIONER WATER DIRECTOR AND
EVEN AT UC MERCED. UP I HAVE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS AND I'LL
TRY TO STEP THROUGH THEM A
RELATIVELY QUICKLY INTO FIRST
TWO IRONICALLY ARE ABOUT THINGS
THAT ARE. IN MY SENATE DISTRICT
BUT THERE STATEWIDE ISSUES AND
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT THE- THE
COASTAL COMMISSION RECENTLY
TOOK INACTION WITH REGARD TO
OCEANIC DUNES A STATE PARK AND
THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE. AND I WAS
GONNA ASK- JUST FIRST BROTHER
DIRECTLY WHETHER STATE PARKS
INTENDS TO COMPLY WITH THE-
DIRECTION OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THAT CAME OUT OF
THAT HERE. SENATOR LAYERED IT
IS GREAT TO SEE YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION. THE NEW
CONDITIONS REYES COMPLEX ISSUE
REGARDING THE OPERATION OF THE
MANAGEMENT OF OCEANIA JONES ALL
OF WHICH STATE PARKS NEEDS TO
CONSIDER. I AM WORKING WITH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST HELP LOWER IT MIGHT THESE
NEW CONDITIONS. THE COMMISSION
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP
UNDERSTANDS THE BEES ARE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO MAKE IN
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FULLY
CONSIDER THE POTENTIAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF THESE
DECISIONS AND HOW BEST TO
OPERATIONALIZE THEM. IS RESPECT
TO OUR RESOURCES PROTECTION
PROJECTS OPERATIONS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PUBLIC ACCESS AS WE
PROCEED. THE COMMISSION
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP AGREES
THAT THE CONDITIONS NEED TO BE
BETTER DEFINED IN LIGHT OF
THINGS LIKE THE SHOREBIRD
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS LAST
MEDICATION PROGRAMS AND PUBLIC
ACCESS WHICH WE NEED TO
CONTINUE AND THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ABOUT MUCH
MORE THAN JUST ALWAYS BE AXLES.
AND MAYBE TO PUT A FINER. POINT
ON IT- DOES THAT BECAUSE THE
SAN LUIS OBISPO PAPERS ALREADY
SAID THERE SOME. OUR THAT THEY
DIRECTED THAT ARE NOT BEING
COMPLIED WITH DO I ASSUME THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION STAFF. THEY HAVEN'T
GIVEN YOU PERMISSION TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT IN THERE.
BUT THEIR DIRECTION AT THIS
POINT HAVE THE- NO THEY
HAVEN'T- WHAT I MEAN I CAN GIVE
YOU A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
ARROYO GRANDE CREEK CROSSING-
IS A REALLY COMPLEX OPERATIONAL
ISSUE AMONG WHICH THEY PUT
FORWARD. BY DIRECTED AND IT IS
CURRENTLY THE ONLY WAY TO GAIN
ACCESS INTO THE OCEANIA REGIONS
SBRA AND THE COMMISSION STAFF
EXECUTIVE STEP OF GREASE THAT
THIS CONDITION NEEDS TO BE
BETTER DEFINED. IN LIGHT OF
SHOREBIRD CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
AND DUST MITIGATION PROGRAMS
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS FOR
CAMPING OF THAT WE STILL WANT
TO CONTINUE AND ALSO
DETERMINATION ALWAYS BE IS
THREE YEARS OUT IN TERMS OVER
SUPPOSED TO END UP BUT RIGHT
NOW- WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SOLVE HOW WE CAN EVEN ACCESS
THE AREA GIVEN THE- DIRECTIVE.
AND I'M SORRY I'M SORRY IT TOOK
JUST KEEP PUTTING UP A FINER
POINT ON IT. IF THEY'RE SAYING
IT NEEDS TO BE BETTER DEFINED
TO SET MEAN THAT YOU HAVE TO
COMPLY. WITH THAT UNTIL THEY
BETTER DEFINE IT. WE'RE WORKING
TO DEFINING THEM I AM MEETING
WITH THE EXACT TO. WEEKLY AND
WE'VE ALSO HAD OUR STAFF
WORKING ON THE OPERATIONAL
PLANS SO THAT WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT THIS MEANS IN
TERMS OF. PUBLIC SAFETY
RESOURCES PROTECTION AND REALLY
KEEPING IN MIND THE MISSION OF
THE STATE PARK SYSTEM WHICH WE
NEED TO BE APPLIED AS WE GO
FORWARD. ARM IN ANOTHER RELATED
QUESTION THERE APPEARS TO BE OF
LEGAL ACTION THAT'S GOING TO BE
TAKEN AGAINST THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ON THIS ARE YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON STATE
PARKS BEING INVOLVED IN ANY
LEGAL ACTION. THANK YOU FOR
THAT CRITICAL QUESTION- AS I
SAID. AS WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE SEAT WITH THE CONSERVATION
CORPS PM COASTAL COMMISSION
RATHER. UNDERSTOOD AND THE STOP
RACIAL PUBLIC ACCESS ISSUES- OF
ANY POTENTIAL DECISION RELATED
DEPARTMENTS POSITION ON LEGAL
CHALLENGES WOULD NEED TO BE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE COUNCIL
SO AT THIS POINT I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. THEY JUST PUT IT
JUST AS A COMMENT IT'S THE
ISSUE OF WHETHER. STATE PARKS
COMPLIES WITH THIS SORT OF IT
IS THE POLAR OPPOSITE OF LEGAL
ACTION IS TAKEN TO FIGHT THE
DECISION. FROM WHAT WE'VE THAT
AND THEN GO TO THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT IS BIG AND BIG BASS AND
PARK WHICH WAS THE FIRST NON
YOU SOMEBODY PARK IN THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM 95% OF IT BURNED
LAST SUMMER. AND THE PARK IS
CLOSED EVERY FACILITY WHEN I
DROVE THROUGH A FEW DAYS AFTER
THE FIRE. YOU COULD NOT EVEN
TELL WHERE SOME OF THE FORMER
FACILITIES WHERE IT JUST BURNS
SO HOT AND THROUGH THERE WERE
VIEWS THAT NEVER EXISTED
BEFORE. AND THE PARK IS CLOSED
AND IS GOING TO BE CLOSED FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE. ONE OF
THE PLANS BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
LOCAL CONCERN ABOUT MY AND
PARTS OF IT MIGHT RE OPEN AND
WHAT IS THE FINANCIAL SITUATION
OR ARE YOU BEING REIMBURSED.
FOR DISASTER FUNDS TO DO WHAT
YOU NEED TO DO AND WHAT IS THE
SCHEDULE OF PLANNING AND HOW
THE PUBLIC WILL BE INVOLVED IN
AND WHEN THERE MIGHT BE EVEN
PARTIAL ACCESS. THANK YOU FOR
THE SET OF QUESTIONS WITH
REGARDS TO BIG BASS OH I JUST
MENTIONED THAT. MY FIRST DAY ON
THE JOB AS DIRECTOR. I WAS
SWORN IN AT THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER AND SPENT THE
DAY AT THE BIG BASS IN HER
QUARTERS. UP WHILE THE PARK WAS
LITERALLY STILL SMOLDERING-
AND- I'LL LET ME TELL YOU. V.
ANSWERS OF THE QUESTION OR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU JUST ASKED-
FIRST OF ALL WELL I'LL BE AT
THE HIGHEST. THAT THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS
BIZARRE AXLES. WHEN THERE'S A
DEVASTATING FIRE- IN A FORESTED
AREA ONE OF THE FACTS IS THAT A
LOT OF THOSE TREES OR WEAKENED.
AND ACTUALLY. FALL IN CREATING
EXTRAORDINARY HAZARD- STATE
PARKS IS ALTHOUGH WE'VE ALREADY
SPENT. THREE MILLION DOLLARS
MOVING RECALL HAS BEEN TRIMS
JUST ALONG THE ROADS THROUGH
THE PARK. AND WE CONTINUE TO BE
LOOKING AT SAFETY HAZARDS WHICH
IS OUR PRIMARY CONCERN BEFORE
VISITORS CAN VISIT THE PARK.
AND SO THE TIME AT WHICH THE
PARK WILL BE OPEN FOR PEOPLE TO
EVEN SEE THINGS ITS USE-
RECENTLY- IS STILL OUT ON THE
HORIZON I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
DATE. BUT REALLY THE CLOSURE IS.
DUE TO VISIT OUR SAFETY. WE
IMMEDIATE ASSUME. TEAM POST
FIRE TO START THINKING ABOUT.
HOW DO WE READ THIS FIRST STATE
PARK IT WAS JUST. AND WE PUT
OUR HEADS TOGETHER AND REALLY
WHAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IS REBUILD A STATE PARK WHAT
IS FUTURE. WHAT IS A STATE PARK
LOOK LIKE IN THE CENTURY WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO INCLUDE
SUSTAINABLE THE SIGNS. ARE WE
PUTTING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
RIGHT PLACE. UTILITIES HOW CAN
WE PLACE THESE TO PROTECT THE
RESOURCES BUT ALSO PROVIDE
SERVICES. FOR THE PUBLIC THAT'S
VISITING UP. WE ARE LOOKING AT
OVERALL PLANNING AS WE PLAN THE
PARK HAVING TO DO WITH HABITAT
AND BIODIVERSITY MANAGEMENT.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO BE THINKING
OF A PARK THAT IS ACCESSIBLE
FOR ALL AND AS WE'VE SEEN WITH
KOBE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE MORE VISITORS THAN THERE
HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST VIRTUALLY
ALL THE PARKS. SO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE GUIDING NATIONAL
JUST. AB IS A QUICKLY AND THAT.
ARE PART TEAMS HAVE ALREADY.
PUT TOGETHER A BASIC. FRAMEWORK
OF A PLAN I THINK OF IT IS
SETTING THE TABLE. FOR WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND WE'RE
PREPARING TO DO A PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS AS LITERALLY
AS WE REIMAGINE. WHAT THE BIG
BASS AND FOR THE NEXT CENTURY
IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE. AND I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT. BEING ABLE TO
WORK ON THE RECOVERY OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY PLACE. AT THE
SAME TIME POTENTIALLY BE
SETTING NEW STANDARDS. IN TERMS
OF HOW WE LOOK. AT WHAT PARTS
NEED TO BE HELD PARTS NEED TO
BE MANAGED AND TAKEN CARE OF
GOING INTO THE NEXT CENTURY.
WITH YOUR QUESTION REGARDING
FINANCING WE HAVE MANY WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A REQUEST FOR
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM FEMA AND
OTHER AGENCIES AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT VARIOUS FUNDING
SOURCES TO HELP. ADVANCE THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND I CAN
ALSO SAY THAT ARE PART PARTNERS
IN SEEING THE WORK THAT WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED ARE ALREADY
FUND RAISING TO PARK IT WAS
PARKS AS WE REBUILD THIS FIRST
STATE PART. OF THE FIRST BIG
PART IN THE STATE PARK SYSTEM
THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE. OF LOCAL
YOU'RE VERY INTERESTED IN JUST
GETTING IN WHEN IT IS SAFE
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY THINK THEY
CAN EVEN HELP RAISE MONEY SO
THAT'S AN- IMPORTANT THING. I
HAD A CUTTING EDGE I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON THE
BUDGET A. M. ONE IS THAT. THE
FIRST MAJOR SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO THE PARK
SYSTEM CAME FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL. AND IT
WAS SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR. A HAVE YOU INVESTED
THAT AND THAT HASN'T BEEN
OFFSET BY ANY CUT IN THE
GENERAL FUND DRIVE THAT IS A
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR MOVE
AHEAD IN THE PARKS BUDGET.
THAT'S CORRECT INITIALLY WE
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
EIGHTY BUT THAT WAS A MISTAKE
IT IS SIXTY EIGHT MILLION AND
IT IS NOT BEING UP. THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING COMING OUT OF OUR BASE
BUDGET AS A RESULT OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND WHAT KINDS OF
THINGS ARE YOU ABLE TO DO THAT
YOU WEREN'T DOING BEFORE NOW
THAT YOU HAVE THE FIRST BIGGEST
SLUG OF ADDITIONAL MONEY IN.
RECENT YEARS. WELL IT'S AN
EXCITING PROSPECT WHAT WE DID
IS WE LOOKED IT UP- FILLING
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WE'VE
ALREADY FILLED TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE POSITIONS. MOST OF US
AREN'T MAINTENANCE AND WITH
CODE AND THE OTHER THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED THAT WORK IS SLOW
DOWN. BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO
OBLIGATE ALL OF THOSE FUNDS IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. AND THAT LEADS
TO THE QUESTION ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SO WHAT'S THE
BALANCE OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IN THE PARK SYSTEM AT THIS
POINT. WELL FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE ARE LOOKING AT-
BEING ABLE TO INVEST. TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN IN OUR
CURRENT BUDGET PASS. AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH REGARDS TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. IS A FEW
YEARS AGO WE WORK WITH THE
STATE PARKS COMMISSION
ESTABLISHED FRAMEWORK THE
PRIORITIES OF A PRIORITY SAME
PROCESS RATHER- AND THE PROJECT
SELECTION CITERIA INCLUDES
GLORIFIED ASPECTS OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY. FEASIBILITY AND
PERMITTING CRITICALITY
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES AND
SAVING AND CODE COMPLIANCE AND
WHEN THESE ARE EVALUATED TO GET
MENTAL MERICLE SCHOOL. AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS. FOR ORDER KEEP
DANCE TO LOWEST AND WE HAVE
BEEN PREPARING FOR IS BEING
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES SO EVERY
TIME WE LOOK AT A PROJECT GET
IT COULD THROUGH THE SCORING
PROCESS AND IT'S ADDED TO THE
LIST. AND OUR IDEA IS THAT
SHOULD WE ARE. OPPORTUNITY
ARISE THAT WE GET FUNDING FOR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DOLLARS WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
PREPARED WITH PROJECTS THAT ARE
READY TO GO WHETHER IT'S- A
SINGLE GET A SINGLE. PROJECT
VALUE OF INCOME OR FUNDING
RATHER FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF INCOME OR FUNDING AND WE
HAVE THESE PROJECTS GO. AND
READY TO GO AND THEY DO CHANGE
A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE SOMETIMES
FUNDING COMES AND IT TAKES CARE
OF A PROJECT UNLESS. SOMETIMES
A NEW PROJECT GETS EVALUATED
MOST OF THE TOP OF THE LIST. SO
IT'S A IT'S A MOVING TARGET BUT
WE ARE. POISED I THANK YOU TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF STREAMS OF FUNDING
THAT COULD REALLY MAKE A DENT
IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I
APPRECIATE THAT. I HAVE SOME
VAGUE KNOWLEDGE OF THAT
PRIORITIES ARE SETTING PROCESS
FROM HERE THERE WAS A TIME WHEN
THERE WERE ESTIMATES OF HOW
MUCH THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WISE. AT ONE POINT IT WAS UP TO
AS HIGH AS A BILLION DOLLARS DO
YOU HAVE ANY CURRENT ESTIMATE
OF. HOW MUCH IS IN THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. IT'S HARD THAN
BILLION- AND IF. BUT I CAN'T BE
IN A MINUTE TO GET THAT NUMBER
TO YOU BUT I DO KNOW THAT IT'S
HIGHER THAN BILLION. AND THEN
ONE LAST BUDGET QUESTION. A
PARKS WAS ALLOCATED A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY FROM THE
MARIJUANA DESTRUCTIVE IN THE
TAX MONEY ARE YOU RECEIVING
THAT MONEY. WHAT'S IT GO FOR.
WE ARE- WE ACTUALLY HELLO THERE
WAS AN ASSESSMENT- HAVING TO DO
IS GOING TO DIRECT THAT MONEY
THANK YOU FOR ASKING THIS
QUESTION AND IT REALLY LOOKS TO
BE MEDIATION HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THE IMPACT OF MARIJUANA
GROWS AND FUNDING THAT'S
RELATED TO- SUPPORTING THE
MARIJUANA ERADICATION AND THERE
ARE THINGS ON THERE THAT ALSO.
EGRESS AND M. AND- INGRESS THE
ROADS OF THE PASSENGER BUILT
INTO THESE PLACES. AND THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT COMES FROM
BORROWED FROM. THE MARIJUANA
INITIATIVE IS SPLIT BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND STATE PARKS.
STATE PARKS GETS 40% AND STATE
OFFICIALS GET 60% INTERESTING
BECAUSE I WONDERED WHAT THAT
SPLIT. I TOLD YESTERDAY IN THE
MEETING THAT INITIALLY STATE
PARKS THOUGHT THEY DESERVED 80%
AND LIKE TWO. AND WHILE I
THOUGHT THEY DESERVED EIGHTY
AND PARKS TWENTY SO I'M
INTERESTED TO HEAR THE SWEAT
THEN I WANTED TO ASK YOU WHEN
THERE WERE SOME PROBLEMS IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT- NOW SEVEN OR
EIGHT YEARS AGO. THERE WAS A
MAJOR REFORM PROCESS UNDERTAKEN
TO REFORM DIFFERENT PIECES OF
THE PARK SYSTEM I WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THE STATUS OF SOME OF
THOSE REFORMS IN ONE OF FROM.
THAT WAS SIGNIFICANT IS THAT IT
USED TO BE THAT YOU HAD TO BE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE IN
MANAGEMENT IN CERTAIN KEY
PIECES OF THE SYSTEM AND IT WAS
REFORM TO ALLOW ANYBODY TO
PROMOTE FROM ANY PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND IT WAS. A
DIVERSITY ISSUE AS PART OF A
JUST A MORALE ISSUE WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THAT IN FILLING THE
POSITIONS AND WHO HOLDS THE
POSITION. SET AT THAT REGIONAL
LEVEL- ARE WHOLE TO THAT DID.
AND THE PREVIOUS DIRECTOR- AS
AS YET I THINK YOU'RE WELL
AWARE WORKED ON THAT. AND WE
ARE APPOINTING SUPERINTENDENTS
IN SUPERMAJORITY- MANAGERS WHO
DO NOT HAVE A COMMISSION. OF
WHICH IS IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CERTIFICATION- AND BAGGAGE- AND
IT WE ARE ANNOUNCING POSITIONS
ARE RECRUITING FOR WHAT IS
REFERRED TO AS NON BADGE. OF
PROFESSIONALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT- PROFESSIONALS. CAN
APPLY FOR THE POSITIONS BUT
THEY CAN NO LONGER BE PEACE
OFFICERS IF THEY GO INTO THOSE
POSITIONS. AND THERE WAS AN
ISSUE WITH STATE PARKS THAT UP
TILL EIGHT OR NINE YEARS AGO
YOU ALMOST COULD NOT PAY
ELECTRONICALLY ANYWHERE IT WAS
CASH ONLY. AND THERE WAS THIS
ELABORATE PROCESSES START TO
MOVE TO THE ABILITY TO PAY
ELECTRONICALLY ACROSS THE STATE
PARKS WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THAT
THIS WE'VE ACTUALLY MODERNIZE
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
CENTER LAYERED- WE'VE MODERNIZE
YOUR RESERVATION SYSTEMS
ACTUALLY OPERATED BY. A
CONTRACT IN RESERVES CALIFORNIA
NOT ONLY DID THEY COLLECT
REVENUE BUT THEY ALSO COLLECT
DATA WHICH IS REALLY USEFUL FOR
US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
BUSINESS ARTS ARTS. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THESE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX I THINK SEPARATE
LOCATIONS THAT ARE INTEGRATED
WITH RESERVE CALIFORNIA. WITH
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PARKS-
PEOPLE CAN USE CREDIT CARDS FOR
PAYMENT AND THERE'S ALSO. NEW
TECHNOLOGY OUT CARDS WITH
PEOPLE CAN PAY WITH A CREDIT
CARD OR IN SOME CASES EVEN OF
FOLLOWED. BY ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING A PARKS
IS WE'VE BEEN ADDING WIFI
CAPABILITY AT PARKS AND RIGHT
NOW ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS HAVE.
WIFI INCOME AVAILABLE FOR
VISITORS AND BECAUSE SOME OF
THE PARKS ARE IN VERY REMOTE
LOCATIONS AND WIFI IS A
DIFFICULT THING TO GET SET UP.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER
TWO HUNDRED OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY STATE PARKS. THAT
HAVE WIFI. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO- DO THEIR STATE BUSINESS SO
YOU'RE PHASING OUT THE SO
CALLED IRON RANGERS. YES AND
THEN ANOTHER OF THE DIGITAL
ISSUES IS THAT GOOGLE WORKED IN
CONCERT WITH THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM TO DIGITISE THE TRIALS
AND PUT THEM ONLINE SO PEOPLE
COULD SEE WHAT THEY WERE
GETTING INTO BEFORE WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THAT PROJECT HELLO
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
I MEAN THE MULTI MEDIA WORLD IS
A IS AN AREA THAT PARTS IS
REALLY STEPPING INTO M. AS PART
PARTNERS- AND OTHER GROUPS
COMING IN LIGHT WILL TRACTOR
IT'S REALLY AN ADVANTAGE TO THE
VISITORS- AND RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE FIFTY. A LITTLE OVER
FIFTEEN STATE PARKS WHERE YOU
CAN GO AND LOOK AT GOOGLE
TREKKER WHICH LITERALLY YOU CAN
WALK WITH SOMEBODY DOWN A TRAIL
WHOSE NEWS CARRIED A BACKPACK
WITH THE CAMERA AND YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SEE WHAT THE LANDSCAPE
OF THE COAST AREA LOOKS LIKE-
AND THEY'RE ALSO FIFTY STATE
BEACHES WHERE YOU CAN FIND
APPROVAL TRACKER WALKS ONLINE
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT PLACES
WHERE WE CAN- OFFER SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES IN TERMS OF GOING
INTO A HISTORIC BUILDING OR
HISTORIC COMPLEX THEY GONNA
DOBIE AND I DO KNOW FROM
EVERYWHERE DECEMBER SAID THAT
THERE WAS A BIG PROJECTS TO.
DIGITIZE ALL OF BODHI SO THAT A
VISITOR REMOTELY COULD
LITERALLY WALKS REBOTE AND GO
AGAINST BUILDINGS AND IT'S
REALLY IT'S REALLY AN EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY. FOR MORE ACCESS TO
PARKS. AND THEN THERE WAS THIS%
WHY GROUP SO UP THE A STATEWIDE
NOT. TO RAISE MONEY TO ASSIST
THAT DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE WHAT'S
THE STATUS OF THAT GROUP. THANK
YOU AND I BELIEVE YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT CARS CALIFORNIA WHATEVER
FRIENDS GROUPS YEAH- THEY ARE
AN AMAZING PARTNER ALONG WITH
THE OTHER PART PARTNERS THAT WE
HAVE. A PARKS CALIFORNIA IS A
LITTLE SEPARATING WARRIOR
YOU'RE- A CLASS ACT GOVERNMENT
AT ALL GROUP. WE MAY WITH THEM
AND OUR OTHER PART PARTNERS
REGULARLY SO THAT WE ARE
COORDINATING OUR EFFORTS
RELATIVE TO PROJECT PRIORITIES
AND FUND RAISING NEEDS OF AND
PARKS CALIFORNIA IS I THINK A
VERY IT'S A ROBUST ORGANIZATION
AS ARE THE OTHERS- THE OF THE-
SEMPERVIRENS FUND SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE. AND THE STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION THEIR OTHER
PARTNERS BECAUSE OUR FOR THE
BIG ONES AND THEY REALLY ARE
CRUCIAL OF NOT ONLY IN HELPING
US ADVANCE OUR PRIORITIES OUT
INTO THE PUBLIC. WITH THINGS
LIKE ACCESS FOR ALL. AND ARE.
INITIATIVE BUT WITH OF THE CAR
WORKING OF WITH CAL. IS I
BELIEVE- IT'S A GREAT PARTNER
AND REALLY AND IT'S EXCITING
EVOLUTION THAT PARTNERING PARKS
WITH. YOU MENTIONED OTHER
PARTNERS IN THE INTERESTING
THING WAS IS THERE WAS NOT A
LEGAL FRAMEWORK UNDER STATE
LAW. TO HAVE PARTNERS FOR
INDIVIDUAL PARKS BE FORMALLY
RECOGNIZED AND- THAT WAS A DON
AND THE M. AS IN THE- UNTIL
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS GO PARKS
DIDN'T ACCOUNT FOR HOW MUCH
EACH INDIVIDUAL PART COST IT
WAS ONLY BY REGION AND SO YOU
COULD IF YOU WANT TO HELP AN
INDIVIDUAL PARK YOU COULD
FIGURE IT OUT BECAUSE YOU CAN
FIGURE OU. HOW MUCH IT COST.
SO WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO FORM
INDIVIDUAL PARK. GROUPS FOR
PARK AT THIS POINT. YOU
INCLUDED SEVERAL THINGS THAT
QUESTION LET ME JUST SAY ONE
THING BEFORE I ANSWER THE REST
OF IT AND THAT IS THAT- I
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU COULDN'T
TELL. HOW A BUDGET WAS BEING
ALLOCATED WITHIN A DISTRICT-
BUT TODAY WITH SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE
WHERE MONEY IS GOING TO A
PROJECT. TO PARK TO DISTRICT SO
THAT SORT OF FINANCIAL TRACKING
HIS IN PLACE AND AGAIN THAT'S
DUE TO SERVICE. UP SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING. AND THE
RELATIVE TO- PART PARTNERS. AND
PARKS THERE'S A COUPLE OF
DISTINCTIONS. OF ONE OF THEM IS
THAT- ANY PARK CAN HAVE A PARK
PARKER. THAT RAISES MONEY FOR
THE MINUTE MIGHT BE A SMALL
LOCAL GROUP. OF WHICH THAT
EXIST ALL OVER THE STATE WHERE
IT CAN BE A RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUP THAT DOES FUNDRAISERS OF
SORTS. BUT IT CAN ALSO BE
LARGER GROUPS THAT LIKE THE
ONES THAT I MENTIONED THAT
MIGHT RAISE FUNDS FOR A CERTAIN
TYPE OF PARKER'S CERTAIN REGION
OF PARKS. BUT I MENTIONED
THERE'S TWO OTHER THINGS THAT
APPLY TO YOUR- QUESTION I
BELIEVE IN ONE OF THEM IS THAT.
PARKS PARTNERS WITH
MUNICIPALITIES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO HELP MANAGE PARKS
SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE STATE
PARKS. THEY BELIEVE THERE'S
ABOUT FIFTY STATE PARKS THAT
ARE MANAGED BY REGIONAL PARK
SYSTEMS AND LOCAL PARK SYSTEMS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH PARKS THEY-
DELIVER THE SERVICES THAT STATE%
PARKS DOES NAY. THEY OFTENTIMES
HAVE. SIGNAGE THAT INDICATES
THAT THIS IS A CALIFORNIA STATE
PARK AND THEN WE HAVE ANOTHER
TYPE OF PARTNER. WHICH IS A- WE
HAVE NON PROFITS THAT ARE
MANAGING PARKS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH PARKS AND WITH THOSE PARKS
WE HAVE CO MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS SO FAR THAT IS WHAT
WAS NOT ALLOWED CO MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS THERE WAS NO LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FORTY FOUR RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE NINE OF THOSE IN PLACE
AND I THINK THAT LEGISLATION
ALLOWED FOR TWENTY OF THEM. AND
WE DON'T REALLY MAKES ALL OF
THIS TECH AND WORK WELL IS WE
HAVE A NEW PARTNERSHIPS OFFICE
AND SO IT'S EXCITING BECAUSE
EACH OF THESE- EFFORTS ARE
CREATING- BASICALLY THE
EXPERTISE WITHIN PARKS TO BE
ABLE TO WORK. WITH ALL OF THE-
COMPLEXITIES OF WORKING WITH
THESE NEW PARTNERS AND I SEE
THAT. AS REALLY AN EXCITING
PATH FOR THE FUTURE THAT
INCREASES SUPPORT FOR PARKS.
THAT DIVERSIFIES THE MANAGEMENT
OF PARKS WHILE KEEPING TO THE
SPIRIT AND TO THE MISSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
SYSTEM. THE REAL STRENGTH S.
AND THEN OFTEN WE HAVE ONE
LAST. QUESTION AND YOU WERE IT
WAS INTERESTING YOU RAISED IT
IN YOUR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS
YOU TALKED ABOUT PARK
ACQUISITIONS. AND I KNOW THERE
WAS THIS STORY NEWS STORY THAT
WAS A YEAR YEAR AND A HALF AGO
THAT BASICALLY SAID- STATE
PARKS HAS BEEN ACQUIRED THROUGH
THINGS AND- IN RECENT YEARS AND
YET. THE STATE BOND MEASURES
THAT HAVE PASSED FOR PARKS. RUN
MONEY THROUGH THE STATE FOR
LOCAL URBAN PARKS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THERE WERE
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
UNDERSERVED PEOPLE. AND SO AND
THE PARKS FORWARD THE REFORM
PROCESS SAID THERE SHOULD BE A
PARK EVERY SO OFTEN. AND THEY
WERE RELEASE NOT DRAWING THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN STATE PARKS
AND MONEY FOR URBAN PARKS WHERE
THERE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
A AND YET YOU ALSO SAID. GOOD
TALKING ABOUT ACQUISITION OF
NEW PARKS SO. ARE ARE YOU
COMMITTED TO THAT PROCESS OF
THE URBAN PARKS MONEY GOING
THERE THE WHITE SPECIFIED AND
DO YOU HAVE ACQUISITIONS. IN
LINE AND I KNOW YOU SOMETIMES
YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE MOLESTED THE PRICE UP. DO
YOU HAVE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
THINKING. OF FOR THE PARKS
SYSTEM ITSELF. AGAIN THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED YOUR HITTING A
NUMBER OF OUR VERY HIGH
PRIORITIES. AND WE ARE LOOKING
AND WE CONTINUE TO KEEP A FOLIO
OF. OF POTENTIAL ACQUISITIONS
THAT WE CAN MAKE AND THOSE
ACQUISITIONS CAN BE ABOUT.
LANDS IT REALLY INCREASE ACCESS
CAN BE ABOUT LANDS THAT ARE
UNIMPORTANT CONNECTING PEACE
WITHIN AN EXISTING STATE PARK
OR IT CAN BE LANDS AND ACTUALLY
BRING UP A VERY CRITICAL
ELEMENT OF A- PARTICULARLY
PROTECTED LANDSCAPE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT INTO AN
EXISTING STATE PARK. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT ACQUISITIONS BUT
THERE'S ANOTHER PIECE TO I
THINK TO YOUR QUESTION THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS. AND FOR
ME THIS WAS A SURPRISE WHEN I.
STEPPED INTO THIS POSITION.
TAKE PARKS HAS THREE GRANTS
PROGRAMS ONE IN STATE PARKS
WHICH IS IN THE OFFICE OF
GRANTS AND LOCAL SERVICES ONE
IN THE OFFICE. WE B. E. ICAL
PROGRAM AND OFFER YOU. A
VEHICLE PROGRAM IN THE BOATING
AND WATERWAYS PROGRAM WHICH
ALSO HAS GRANTS ARE BOTH FUNDED
BY GAS TAXES THE OFFICE OF
GRANTS AND LOCAL SERVICES THIS
GRANT IS FUNDED BY THINGS LIKE
PROPOSITION EIGHT- M. PROP ONE
OR SB ONE AND ON THE LAND AND
WATER CONSERVATION FUND IN
THOSE SORTS OF MONIES. I WAS
REALLY SURPRISED WHEN I
DISCOVERED OR REALIZED THAT
SINCE HE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
STATE PARKS HAS DIRECTED
COMMUNITY GRANTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SINCE INSTEAD COME.
SINCERE TWO THOUSAND TO THE
TUNE OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THESE FUNDS HAVE GONE TO
THINGS LIKE NATURE CENTERS
TRAILS EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
ZOOS BUILDING A COMMUNITY POOL
FOR A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY THAT
DIDN'T HAVE A POOL. I MEAN IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT DELIVERY OF RESOURCES
TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I REALLY WANT TO DO
AND AM ALREADY STARTING TO DO
IS TO PROMOTE THE FACT THAT
STATE PARKS IS ALSO DIRECTING
FUNDS TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE I PERSONALLY
FEEL THAT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FEEL
OWNERSHIP ABOUT THE PARKS AND
NOTHING LIKE OWNERSHIP AROUND
PARKS LIKE HAVING ONE IN YOUR
TOWN. WELL THE NEXT TIME PAUL
ROGERS CALLS YOU AND SAYS
THERE'S NOT BEEN ANY MONEY PUT
INTO STATE PARKS IN RECENT
YEARS YOU START THAT STATISTIC
IN EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST SAID
SO THAT HE KNOWS THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING. IN
ANY EVENT. I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TRACKING WITH ME ON ALL
THE QUESTIONS AND OBVIOUSLY I
COULD HAVE GONE ON BUT I ALSO
WANT TO THANK. OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR INDULGENCE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE PARKS DIRECTOR
WHICH WE BARELY HAVE A CRACK
AT. ARE THERE ARE INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF ISSUES AND
COMPLEXITIES AND- ARE JUST
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY OF BEARING
WITH US GETTING INTO A MESS
HERE. THE SENATOR LIAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH- WE APPRECIATE YOU
ASKING THE QUESTIONS- IT'S
IMPORTANT- WITH THAT LET ME.
IT'S NOT OFTEN WE HAVE THE
FORMER SECRETARY- AS A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE WHO KNOWS A
LOT MORE THAN MOST OF US DO SO.
I THINK IT ALLOWS US TO LEARN A
LOT- THAT WE WOULDN'T
ORDINARILY HAVE. HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF INFORMATION SO WE
APPRECIATE IT- EVEN AS WE
LAMENT YOUR- DIRECTOR YOU'RE
HAVING TO ANSWER ALL THOSE
QUESTIONS ABOUT. ACTUALLY IT'S
GOOD- LET ME GO TO- THE VICE
CHAIR NOW FOR HER COMEDY
QUESTIONS CENTERED BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M- DIRECTOR
CAN TOP QUINTERO I THINK I GOT
IT RIGHT THIS TIME WE HAD A
GREAT CONVERSATION EARLIER IN
THE DAY SO IN THE ON ON. MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE TO THE RIGHT TO
THEIR- COVERED MUCH OF WHAT WE
DISCUSSED OUT THERE WAS ONE
AREA THAT I DIDN'T ASK ABOUT.
AND DOOR QUICKLY ON THE QUICK
QUESTION ON THE HARBOR AND
WATER WATER CRAFT REVOLVING
FUND- AND THE POTENTIAL
REGISTRATION FEE INCREASES ON
VESSELS YOU KNOW DANA POINT
HARBOR. FONG AND OCEANSIDE
HARBOR OR IN MY DISTRICT SO
I'VE HAD FUN A FEW EMAILS
LATELY REGARDING ON THE
POTENTIAL FOR. THE REGISTRATION
FEES FOR OUR ON BOTH ARE GOING
UP AND ONE WAS KIND OF OUT OF
THE PARK SAID IT WAS TWO
HUNDRED AND SOME PERCENT AND I
SAID I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A DECISION ON THAT
AT THE MOMENT BUT CHAO WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
THAT AND HERE YOU ARE SO. MAYBE
GIVE ME A KIND OF AN IDEA OF
WHY STAKEHOLDER PROCESS PERHAPS
IT MIGHT BE GOING ON TO
DETERMINE HOW TO MEET THE
INSOLVENCY IN THE FUNDED BUT
NOT. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
ON THE VIEW THE- VEHICLE
LICENSE FEES ON THEIR BULLETIN
EDITION TO THEIR CARS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE FILL OUT HOW
ARE YOU LOOKING ON THAT AND
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S THE DIRECTION.
IT THAT HAPPENS GOOD AFTERNOON
SURVEYS IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
IMPORTANT QUESTION- THE VOTER
REGISTRATION MEANS- OR BOAT
REGISTRATION FEES HAVE NOT
CHANGED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. THEY ARE STILL WHAT THEY
WERE IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHICH
IS TEN DOLLARS A YEAR- AND
THAT'S ANY SIZE BOAT- AND SO.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THERE'S BEEN A
REDUCTION IN THE FUNDING. FOR
THE MONIES ARE USED TO DO
THINGS LIKE- REMOVES- HAZARDOUS
OR RATHER NAVIGATION HAZARDS TO
REMOVE THE INVASIVE PLANT
SPECIES AND WATER WAYS AND SUCH
AND OTHER. OTHER EXPENSES LIKE
THAT AND SO WHAT WE DID IS. WE
LOOKED AT BORDER REGISTRATION
FEES ACROSS THE NATION AND THE
PROPOSED REGISTRATION FEE THAT
WE HAVE ON THE TABLE IS THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS A YEAR ALL PER
BOAT. AND THAT'S STILL IN THE
LOWEST 5% WE WERE THE LOWEST
FEE IN THE NATION AT TEN
DOLLARS WE ARE THE LOWEST FEE
IN THE NATION AT TEN DOLLARS
FOR VOTER REGISTRATION AND IF
WE BRING IT TO THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS WE'RE STILL GONNA BE IN
THE BOTTOM FIVE. OF THIS NATION
IN TERMS OF VOTER REGISTRATION
FEES AND I DO RECOGNIZE THAT A
CHANGE IN RATES CHANGE FEES.
CAN BE REALLY SHOCKING- BUT WE
THIS REALLY IS MAKING US LOOK
AT HOW ARE THOSE FEES ASSESSED
AND HOW FOR EXAMPLE HOW CAN
FEES PERHAPS JUST KEEP UP WITH
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- BUT IT IT
I. I RECOGNIZE THE SHOCK IT'S
ACTUALLY SOMETHING I'VE SEEN
HAPPEN ALSO IN THE WIDER WORLD
WAS WATER RATES- AND- SO IT'S A
IT IS A PROBLEM WE ARE GOING TO
BE CONTINUING IN A PUBLIC
PROCESS AS WE SET THAT FEE AND
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO A NUMBER
OF GROUPS FROM THE BOATING
COMMUNITY. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THAT THE PICTURE CLEAR
THAT IT'S TEN DOLLARS A YEAR
THE THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS A YEAR
AND WE'RE STILL GOING TO BE IN
THE BOTTOM FIVE OF THE NATION
AT THAT RATE. SO WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE. THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING I AM PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT YOU ARE PURSUING IT
THROUGH LIKE THE VOTER ON
ORGANIZATIONS THAT TIME
CERTAINLY ARE THE MOST
INTERESTED AND CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE AND
WITH THE RECREATIONAL BOATING
OUT THERE SO ENJOYABLE ALONG
OUR COAST AND I JUST KEEP WATCH
ON OUT TO. BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S SOME PERHAPS SOME
MISINFORMATION ON IN TERMS OF
WHEN IT WAS TWO HUNDRED AND
SOME. PERCENT PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND I SAW I DID THINK
WE'RE VERY. BUT I WILL
CERTAINLY CLEAR FRIDAY AND THEN
ON WELL JUST KEEP IN TOUCH WITH
AND HOW THAT IS LOOKING SO I
CAN GET OUT TO THE VOTER
GROUPS. LET'S SEE HERE- BEFORE
THINGS GET KIND OF BILLS SO
INTERPRETED. AND WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP OU INFORMED ON
THE GRAIN WITHOUT TO HARPER
SIGN I GET A LOT OF INPUT IF
YOU WOULD IMAGINE. BUT THANK
YOU ALL FOR ALL YOUR ANSWERS
AND KNOCK I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
TO THE RIGHT THERE ARE. COVERED
COVERED EVERYTHING THAT I
NEEDED. TO KNOW AND- HE- KNOW
YOUR MY- BUT I KNOW. LEFT.
THANK YOU AND- THANKS TAKING
THE TIME IT WAS A GREAT
CONVERSATION PRITCHETT OKAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES ON
MOVES TO CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
I'M MATTER PRO TEN- THANK YOU
DIRECTOR PRINTER FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND ALLOWING US TO ASK
YOU SOME QUESTIONS I DO HAVE TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY'S COMMENTS ABOUT- OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ WHO
ASKED ALMOST EVERY QUESTION
THAT THAT I HAD. A SPECIFICALLY
ON THE OCEANIA DUNES AND- THE
CONFLICT THAT HAS ARISEN OVER
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE I
HAVE A LOT OF- EIGHT YEARS IN
MY COMMUNITY. ET BUT I DO WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON A QUESTION THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ
DID ASK AND IF IT HAD TO DO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT THAT
IDENTIFIED. A ONE POINT THREE
BILLION IT'S OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S THE NUMBER I HAVE
IS A LITTLE OVER ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
AND SO I GUESS IN YOUR OPINION-
HOW SHOULD THE DEPARTMENT
BALANCE THE NEED TO MAINTAIN
THE EXISTING PARKS THAT WE HAVE
THEY'RE IN DESPERATE NEED OF
MAINTENANCE- IN OKAY AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU HAVE NEW
PARK SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE NEW PARKS- THERE HAS
TO BE A BALANCE THERE WHAT YOUR
THOUGHT PROCESS ON. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR. ONE OF MY ANSWERS
TO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS HAD TO
DO WITH PARTNERSHIPS. AND THAT
IS ONE OF THE CONSIDERATIONS-
THAT WE LOOK AT. IN TERMS OF
THESE PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE
REALLY WHEN. BECAUSE WHEN WE
GET A PARTNER IN PLACE IN STATE
CO MANAGEMENT AGREEMENT OR A
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT WITH THE
MUNICIPALITY. WHICH COULD BE A
CITY OR COUNTY- THAT IS WHAT WE
SEEN COST EFFICIENCIES- OF.
THOSE BASICALLY THEY OPERATE
THE PARKS AS WE WOULD. R. COSTA
FAR REDUCE WE STILL ARE THEY
HAVE BEEN PURCHASED IN STATE
PARK PURCHASED WITH STATE PARK
FUNDS. AND WE ALL ARE ABLE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE
ENTITIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE MANAGED- IN THE
FRAMEWORK THAT STATE PARKS
MANAGES PARKS SO THAT IS A
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION IN TERMS
OF FUNDING WE DO LOOK. AT FACT
THAT IS ONE OF THE CRITERIA
WILL BE LOOK AT- PROPERTIES ARE
LANDS WHAT IS IT GOING TO COST.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO COST TO
MANAGE AND OR WILL WE BE ABLE
TO DO IT AND IF WE CAN'T DO IT
WHAT KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS
COULD MAKE THIS WORK IF IT'S A
HIGH PRIORITY. THANK YOU. I DO
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION YOU KNOW
WITH THE WAY THINGS ARE GOING
I'M NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS OUR NATION ON A RE
EXAMINING OUR PAST IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY. I KNOW
THAT- PARKS ARE NO DIFFERENT
AND GIVE IT THE PARKS ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WERE GONNA LOOK AT A
LIST OF NAMES OF PARKS THAT
REST ABLATION. UNDER THAT AND
RE EXAMINING OUR PAST CAN YOU
GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
YOUR VISION IS IN YOUR GOALS ON
THAT INITIATIVE WOULD BE. AND
IS IT GOING TO BE INCLUSIVE AND
INCLUDE ALL STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WOULD HAVE- ED A DIVERSE
OPINIONS. OF RENAMING SPECIFIC
PARTS OF PARKS I AM. I AM NO
WAY DISMISSING ANY OF OUR
NATION'S PASTIME I JUST THINK
THAT THERE IS- THERE IS A LOT
OF HISTORICAL VALUE- GOOD OR
BAD. THAT ARE DRESSED IN SOME
OF THE NAMES OF OUR PARKS AND
SERVICE JUST CURIOUS WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS WERE ON THAT. SENATOR
I'M SO GLAD YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE I KNOW. I KNOW
WHAT THIS STORY BRINGS UP JUST
IN ANY COMMUNITY THAT'S
CONSIDERING NAME CHANGES. YEAH
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHAT WE
ARE PUTTING TOGETHER. IS A
ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS- AND THAT
INCLUDES BRINGING IN A HIGH
LEVEL ADVISORY COMMITTEE. OF
EXPERTS FROM UNIVERSITIES AND
FROM A DIVERSITY OF
PERSPECTIVES. HISTORIANS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE WORKING. TO
REVIEW NAMES A PROBLEM BEFORE
THE GROUP- AND THAT WILL
INCLUDE MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
FINDING OUT WHAT THE WHOLE
STORY BUT REALLY THE BASIS OF
WHAT WE WANT TO DO. BECAUSE
PARKS ARE ABOUT NATURAL HISTORY
AND CULTURAL HISTORY AND WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TELL THE
FULL STORY OF HISTORY NOT JUST
HAVE NAMES THAT ARE REALLY
REMAINS OR- STORIES ARE NOT
TOLD THAN WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT THROUGHOUT PARKS AND I CAN
SEE THIS FROM MY PHONE BACK.
BACKGROUND WHAT. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS UNTOLD STORIES AND
PARKS SO HOW DO THEY FIT
TOGETHER IN TERMS OF PEOPLE'S
FAMILY HISTORY IN A PARKING THE
PLACES A DAY GONE AND VISITED
AND COME TO KNOW AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE ATTACHMENTS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE. TO NAMES- BUT WE WANT TO
BE NOT ONLY VERY CAREFUL IN THE
NAMES THAT WE CONSIDER BUT WE
WANT TO BE ABSOLUTELY TO USE
THE WORD YOU USED INCLUSIVE.
AND HOW WE HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND IF THERE'S ANY
DECISION THAT WAS GOING TO BE
MADE OR THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
NAY ABOUT A NAME OR A NAME
CHANGE. THAT'S GOING TO GO TO
THE CALIFORNIA PARKS COMMISSION
AND THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC
NOTICE AND IT WOULD BE A PUBLIC
HEARING IN CONVERSATION. BEFORE
THERE'S ANY STARTED CHANGE
RELATIVE TO A NAME AND PARKS.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT I
AM SEEING. THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CARSON IF YOU
AREAS WHERE BIRDS HAVE. BEEN
EFFORTS YOU- BEEN MADE. THE
STORIES A FULLER STORY IT'S A
DEEPER STORY IT'S A IT'S A
BIGGER STORY AND NOTHING
DISAPPEARS IT JUST BECOMES A
BETTER STORE A BIGGER STORY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
EXCITED ABOUT IS THAT I REALLY
BELIEVE. THAT PARKS NEED TO BE
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE CAN SEE
THEMSELVES WHETHER THEY'RE THE
TWO HUNDRED GENERATION FROM
THIS WEEK. OR FIRST GENERATION
AND SO AGAIN TO USE YOUR WORD
OUR EFFORT. IS REALLY ABOUT
INCLUSIVITY. AND I WILL JUST
SAY QUICK AND THEN IS THAT. THE
GOVERNOR. HAS ANOTHER IN.
COMMITTEE WHICH IS CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA ADVISORY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON GEOGRAPHIC NAMES
AND THAT'S A DIFFERENT PROCESS
THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING. I JUST
TALKED ABOUT PARTS. THANK YOU I
DIRECTOR CAN TERO FOR ANSWERING
THOSE QUESTIONS I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP THAT
YOU'VE OFFERED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE LET ME MOVE TO SENATOR
COLLAR. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
MISTER CONTATTO I THINK LAST
TIME I SAW YOU YOU HAD GUITARS
BEHIND YOU. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU MOVE THEM BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T WANT US TO MENTION THEM.
I KNOW TO PLAY- I WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
I'VE WE HAD A WONDERFUL.
DISCUSSION YOU AN ID EITHER ON
MONDAY OR TUESDAY THAT'S HOW
OLD MY BRAIN IS- AND WAS SO
STRUCK BY YOU SHARING YOUR
STORY AND TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU
DECIDED TO. TAKE SOME TIME OFF
TO FIGURE OUT WHO YOU WERE- AND
I THINK THAT. KIND OF SELF
AWARENESS AND CONNECTEDNESS TO
THE EARTH AND THE SPACES SO
IMPORTANT I THINK FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS IN YOUR POSITION TO LEAD
OUR PARKS- YOU MENTIONED ACCESS
A LOT IN YOUR RESPONSES AND YOU
HAVE THIS VERY INTENSE TASK OF
UNPACKING THAT WORD- AND REALLY
SORT OF IDENTIFYING HOW WE WORK
TO PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO
OUTDOOR SPACE FOR PEOPLE. WHILE
PROTECTING OUR OUTDOOR SPACE
FROM PEOPLE AND HOW BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS HAPPEN I'M SORT OF
SIMULTANEOUSLY I THINK IS THE
TASK THAT YOU HAVE AT HAND SO I
SALUTE YOUR DESIRE TO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT KIND OF
WORK AND FIGURE IT UT MY
QUESTION IS AROUND ACCESS-
IT'S- VERY SPECIFIC. A FRIEND
OF MINE WAS SHARING WITH ME-
HOW YEARS AGO WHEN HE WAS
REALLY YOUNG HE JOURNEYED INTO
A STATE PARK HE WAS ONE OF FOUR
YOUNG BOYS FROM COMPTON. THEY
HAD NEVER BEEN TO A STATE PARK
YOU KNOW IN THEIR LIFE-
RAMBUNCTIOUS YOU KNOW NEEDING
SOME- REAL DISCIPLINE FROM
THEIR PARENTS AND THEY
CONNECTED WITH THESE TWO
MENTORS SLASH GUIDES. WHO TOOK
THEM FOR ABOUT A WEEK DEEP INTO
ONE OF THE STATE PARKS- FOR
THIS AMAZING EXPERIENCE WHERE
THEY WERE ABLE TO SEE. THE
STARS AT NIGHT YOU PACK IN WHAT
YOU PACKED OUT YOU LEARN ABOUT
YOU KNOW BEARS AND- ANIMALS IN
WHO YOU ARE. AND YOU LEARN TO
SURVIVE AND YOU LEARN TO.
DEPEND ON YOU KNOW YOUR FELLOW
TRAVELER. AND AFTER I LEARNED
OF THE STORY I STARTED TO
RESEARCH TO FIGURE OUT WHERE-
OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THIS WOULD
BE FOR OTHER FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN YOU KNOW PARK
POOR COMMUNITIES- AS INTENSE AS
THAT. EXPERIENCE AN OPPORTUNITY
WAS RATHER THAN SORT OF A DATE
TRIP YOU KNOW WHERE YOU GO WITH
THE BUS AND YOU SPEND A COUPLE
OF HOURS ANNUALLY. AND WAS
HAVING A VERY HARD TIME FINDING
THEM AND SO I KNOW WHEN YOUR
RESPONSES YOU MENTIONED A
COUPLE OF PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH
BUT I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD MAYBE EXPAND ON IF THERE
ARE STILL PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED- AND IF
NOT YOU KNOW ARE THERE ARE SORT
OF- DISCUSSIONS IN PLACE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BRING
SOME OF THOSE THINGS BACK
BECAUSE I WAS. REALLY AWESTRUCK
THAT SOMEONE. COULD SHARE A
STORY FROM FORTY YEARS AGO WITH
SUCH A RICHNESS AND CLARITY
THAT I KNEW THAT THAT WAS AN
EXPERIENCE THAT RESONATED WITH
THAT PERSON STILL. AND HOW DO
WE FIND WAYS TO REPLICATE THOSE
KINDS OF EXPERIENCES FROM R.
EIGHT POINT FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TODAY. SENATOR THAT'S A
BEAUTIFUL QUESTION. THERE ARE
PROGRAMS IN PARKS WHICH YOU DO-
DELIVER OPPORTUNITIES- IN OUR A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM WE
ACTUALLY THE STATE PARKS BODIES
CAMPING SUPPLIES SORT OF THE
FAMILY SO THAT A FAMILY DOESN'T
HAVE TO BUY A CAMPING SUPPLIES
THAT THEY CAN CHECK OUT YOU
JUST HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
TRAINING ON HOW TO USE THAT AND
THERE'S LOCKERS AT SEVERAL
PARKS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY. OF CHECK OUT THIS
EQUIPMENT IT'S NOT TO THE LEVEL
OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUT I THINK WITH YOUR QUESTION
RAISES IS AN ANSWER THAT IS
REALLY ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS AND I
CAN GIVE YOU I MEAN I CAN TELL
YOU A LIST OF PARK PARTNERS ALL
I'LL GIVE YOU ONE THERE'S ONE
CALLED ENVIRONMENTAL TRAVELING
COMPANIONS YEAH THEY STARTED
YEARS AGO IN FACT. IN THE LAKE
IN THE MID SEVENTIES I WORKED
WITH THE FOUNDER WHEN THEY JUST
STARTED WORKING AS A PARK
RANGER AND WHAT IF BY MIDDLE
TRAVELING COMPANIONS DOES IS IT
TAKES PEOPLE WHO ARE DISABLED
ON RIVER RAFTING TRIPS ON
KAYAKING TRIPS ON SENATE ON
SKIING TRIPS AND THEY ARE ONE
OF THE PARTNERS IN PART PART IN
AND- THE ONE OF THE PROPERTIES
OF STATE PARKS EXCUSE. AND IT I
AM AWARE AND HAVE WORKED WITH
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT YOU SEE
MERCED THERE ARE TWO PROGRAMS
ONE OF THEM IS CALLED THE USE
THAT MANY LEADERSHIP PROGRAM
WHERE STUDENTS GO OUT WE
ACTUALLY END UP WORKING IN YOU
SOMEBODY IN THE SUMMERTIME
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR NOT ONLY
ARE THEY TAKING CLASSES ON THAT
CAMPUS BUT THEY'RE REACHING OUT
TO SCHOOLS AND PUTTING TOGETHER
PROGRAMS TO GET YOUNG CHILDREN
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT. IN INTO PARTS
WHETHER THEY'RE LOCAL OR
NATIONAL OR STATE PARKS THERE'S
ALSO AN INCREDIBLE PROGRAM
CALLED AN ADVENTURE RISK
CHALLENGE WHICH IS IN THE UC
SYSTEM AND WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
TAKE. CHILDREN WHO ARE KIDS WHO
ARE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL WHO. ARE FROM JUST
ADVANTAGE CAN IN FAMILIES. AND
THEY TAKE A INTO WILL JERRY.
FOR THE FOR DAYS FORTY NIGHTS.
AND IT IS IT IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S GUIDED BY. INSTRUCTORS
AND I HAVE WITNESSED A NUMBER
OF THESE. STUDENTS RETURN FROM
THOSE X. VARIANCES ABSENT.
POLITICALLY CHANGE IF AND WHEN
YOU MEANT IT WAS GIVING A TALK
AFTER HE GOT ON HIS HEAD
GROWING UP PICKING TOMATOES
WITH THIS FAMILY IN FACT HE
DIDN'T WASN'T GOING TO PROGRAM
BECAUSE HE WAS PICKING ONE TO
PICK TOMATOES. BUT AFTER COMING
BACK AND GIVING A SPEECH ABOUT
WHAT HE EXPERIENCED HE ENDED BY
SAYING I WILL NEVER PICK
TOMATOES GET- THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT YOUR QUESTION RAISES. AN
ASTOUNDING- UNDERSTANDING I DO
THAT- I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING-
APPEAR IN MORE PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO- SUPPORTING. YOU IN BEING
ABLE TO BE A PARTNER WITH YOU-
AS I MENTIONED IN OUR
DISCUSSION- THERE YOU'RE SO
ATTUNED TO THIS WORK I THINK
YOUR EXPERIENCE YOUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE YOUR WORK
EXPERIENCE. AND THE ENERGY AND
VIBRATIONS THAT YOU BRING TO
LIVING AND LOVING AND LEARNING
ABOUT PARKS IS REALLY ADMIRABLE
AND SO- I AM SO. VERY GRATEFUL
TO- SUPPORT YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FIGURING OUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN BRING PARKS TO THE
THIRTIETH SENATE-DISTRICT.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WELL LESLIE
OF I ONLY HAVE. ONE QUESTION
AND SOME COMMENTS FOR THE
pWANT TO START BY SAYING THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO OF
MY DISTRICT- STAFF COMMUNICATE
QUITE FREQUENTLY WITH STATE
PARKS ARE STAFF AND HAVE A
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP AND HAVE
HAD- JUST LONG TERM- THE
ABILITY TO GET A GREAT
ASSISTANCE SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I WANT TO THANK
YOU I HAVE NO DOUBT YOU'LL
CARRY ON THAT I THOUGHT THAT.
RELATIONSHIP I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR CHIEF DEPUTY FOR
MEETING WITH MY STAFF. ON A
COUPLE OF ISSUES. IN PARTICULAR
JUST FOR THE RECORD AND TO PUT
IT ON- THE RECORD MUCH LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE ABOUT-
SPECIFIC ISSUES ARE PROJECTS
ARE PARTS THAT ARE VERY NEAR
AND DEAR TO THEIR HEARTS.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE SURPRISED
TO HEAR ME PUT BORDER FIELD
STATE PARK- IN FRONT OF YOU
BECAUSE WE HAD THE
CONVERSATION. WHICH I GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT IS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. I KNOW THE FORMER
SECRETARY REMEMBERS THIS IT'S A
VITAL RECREATIONAL RESOURCE FOR
MANY SAN DIEGANS. IT'S A DEEPLY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE FOR MANY
WHO WANT TO CONNECT WITH LOVED
ONES ACROSS THE BORDER. A GREAT
HISTORY TO THIS ODD TO THIS
PARK. I IN PARTICULAR THE
BORDER WALL FRIENDSHIP PARK.
IT'S BEEN CLOSED I'D TO PUBLIC
ACCESS FOR SOME TIME. AND IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN- WE WORKED WITH
THE FORMER- GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION BROUGHT
ADMINISTRATION TO AUGMENT STATE
PARKS FUNDING. I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT THE FORMER SECRETARY WAS
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION.
ABOUT REPAIR AND RESTORATION OF
THE PARKING REMOVAL OF
CONTAMINATION FROM THE TIJUANA
RIVER. SO I'VE BEEN MY STAFF
HAS BEEN GIVEN A STATUS UPDATE
ON ANY NUMBER OF THIS PROJECT
AND I JUST WANNA. REQUEST
FOLLOW UP ON THE ISSUE ON GOING
WE WANT TO TRACK THIS. ARE
GOING FORWARD- WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENT AS YOU PROCEED ON
THIS AND BE KEPT APPRISED OF
ANY ACTION. BUT I FELT VERY
COMFORTABLE HERE AND THE
RESPONSE BACK FROM. FROM STAFF
ON THE ON THE STATUS SO I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND SAY I'D LOVE TO HAVE THE
ONGOING. ARE UPDATING
COMMUNICATION. M. PRESENT YES-
I WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT AS SOON AS WE ARE ABLE TO
TRAVEL MORE FIELD IS ONE OF THE
FIRST PARKS THAT I NEED TO GO
SEE AND- A WAS VERY EXCITED TO
UNDERSTAND- I THINK THE
INFORMATION A RESEARCHER WITH
YOU THAT WE ARE GONNA BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION- AS WE
DEVELOP THE PLANS TO GET. ORDER
FEELS OPENED UP AGAIN. AND THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR US. SACRAMENTO PARK FOR
MANY REASONS. I APPRECIATE THAT
END UP WALL SOME OF US ARE
TALKING ABOUT DISTRICT SPECIFIC
THINGS OUR WATER I HAVE TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND SAY THANK YOU
TO THE STAFF AT TORREY PINES.
STATE PARK THEY DO AN
INCREDIBLE JOB. I CERTAINLY- WE
APPRECIATE THAT S. AT YET MUCH
LIKE ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO
DOESN'T LOVE PARKS- MY SPOUSE
AND I ARE FREQUENT USERS. OF
THE PARK SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WE FEEL YOU KNOW
REALLY PRIVILEGE THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS. TO THESE PARKS ARE SOME
OF THE BEST IN THE WORLD I
THINK SO. AYE AYES I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
IN OUR COMMENTS ABOUT YOUR
COMMITMENT OBVIOUSLY YOUR
COMPASSION AND YOUR- AYE YOUR
DEEP PERSONAL INTEREST. IN PARK
SO. YOU'LL ALSO HAVE MY SUPPORT
AND- WITH THAT I THINK WE'VE
KEPT ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING LONG ENOUGH BUT THEY
SHOULD BE WELL VERSED ON
EVERYTHING RELATED TO PARKS BY
NOW IF THEY ARE LISTENING. BUT
WITH THAT I AM GOING TO MOVE TO
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE APPOINTMENT WE
WILL START WITH SUPPORT. AND AS
A REMINDER FOR WITNESSES-
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS UP ON THE SCREEN
AGAIN. IT IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. HAVING SAID THAT WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE. IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND I
ACTUALLY DO NOT SEE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND LOOK AT MY
COMPUTER SCREEN AND SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- WHO WISHES TO SPEAK. I
DO NOT SEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO
LET ME WELCOME OUR
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR- FOR
THOSE WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
SO MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
SAW PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ITALY'S IN GERMAN IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I THINK WE HAVE SEVEN
Q. AT THE MOMENT GREAT. MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO REMIND OUR WITNESSES BEFORE-
YOU. CALL THEM TO PROVIDE THEIR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION IF ANY.
AND- A BRIEF POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU GO AHEAD
MR MODERATOR. IN THE FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM. MY NUMBER
ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR NUMBERS TO ANY GIRL ON
BEHALF OF THE PARK NOW
COLLISION AS WELL AS WITH YOU
KNOW HOW TO WORK IN SUPPORT OF
MY MIND A FUTURE CONFIRMATION
AS DIRECTOR STATE PARK WE HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF MEETING WITH MR
KIM CAROL I'M GOOD I'M GOOD I
HAVE TO STOP YOU I NEED TO STOP
YOU I'M REALLY SORRY. OUT I
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE I
MADE THIS STATEMENT WE HAVE A
STENOGRAPHER WHO CAPTURES YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOU MIGHT BE
SPEAKING A LITTLE BIT FAST FOR
HER SO IF YOU WILL START OVER
SLOW DOWN YOU HAVE TIME TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT AND FORGIVE. ME
FOR INTERRUPTING YOU BUT GO
RIGHT AHEAD. NO WORRIES I HAVE.
JAMIE GOING TO HAPPEN PARK NOW
CALLED. AND THE EQUIPPED KNOW
HOW. IN SUPPORT OF OUR MONDO
CARE. IF THE ARE DIRECTOR. WE
THE PLEASURE OF MEETING WITH
MISTER CAROL. WITH HIS
EXPERIENCE AT THE PARK. AND
CATHOLIC DEEPER. THE STATE PARK.
WE'RE EXCITED SEE HIM HAD
DEPARTMENT DRAW FROM THE.
ACTION TO BE A LEADER ON
PROMOTING BACK IN AFFECTED
OCTOBER CALLED HELP. AND WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD IF YOU CAN TO
WORK HIM. AFTER HAD DIRECT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL. NEXT WEEK
MISTER MY. AND NEXT WE GO TO
WIND A LETTER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ATKINS AND
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF NATURE FOR ALL COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION MADONSELA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND
TRUST CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS AND
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY IN
INFINITY AFTER SUPPORT OF MR
COMPARISON APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THE NEXT ONE WE GO TO
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY QUE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CENTER VIRANT FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NECKLINES LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE
YOU- ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITH
OTTOMAN CALIFORNIA- E. AM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE- THE
REMEMBER- HERE FORCONFIRMATION
WE ARE REALLY EXCITED WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MEET WITH- THE-
THE APPOINTEE HERE- I'M I'M I'M
LOOKING AT ALL WE'RE REALLY
DELIGHTED THAT HE HAS BEEN
NOMINATED AND- IN THIS POSITION
WE'VE ALWAYS FOUND THEM TO BE.
ACCESSIBLE VERY THOUGHTFUL-
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE FUTURE
PARKS- I THINK THE CONVERSATION
TODAY ABOUT ACCESS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT NOT JUST
TO OUR ORGANIZATION BUT ALSO-
TO A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS AND WE
THINK THAT HE'S GONNA BE. EIGHT
INCREDIBLE- CHAMPION NOT JUST
ON THAT. ARE ON ACTIVE. HE DID
THE BIODIVERSITY OF THE PARK
THE- HOUSE A LOT. OF BY THE
STAGE ARE ABLE TO MANAGE AND
REALLY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT-
HE TAKES ALL OF IT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE'RE WERE
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF. HIS
NOMINATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR CAN TERO MY
NAME IS KELLY WALSH SMALLER ON
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF PARKS
CALIFORNIA. AS SENATOR LAYERED
MENTION PARKS CALIFORNIA IS THE
NEWER STATUTORY NONPROFIT
PARTNER TO CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS. AT TWO YEARS OLD WE WERE
CREATED TO THE PARKS BOARD
COMMISSION. I'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH DIRECTOR GOING
TOMORROW SINCE HE BEGAN IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE TEAM AT
PARKS CALIFORNIA IS INSPIRED BY
HIS LEADERSHIP. POSITION IN
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO STATE
PARKS MISSION. WE'RE ALSO
DEEPLY RESPECTFUL OF HOW HE
VALUES HIS OWN TEAM. WE WORK
CLOSELY TOGETHER WITH DIRECTOR
QUINN TERO IN HIS TEAM ON
SHARED PRIORITIES THAT FOCUS ON
EQUITY ACCESS TO AN EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION TO NATURAL
RESOURCES PROTECTION AND
STEWARDSHIP. WE BELIEVE
DIRECTOR QUENTIN IS THE RIGHT
LEADER TO DRIVE STATE PARKS
MISSION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER CLOSELY
WITH THE DIRECTOR AND. THE
BROADER STATE PARKS TEAM THANK
YOU. THANK SO MUCH THAT YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AS WELL HI MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. IN
MEXICO MY NUMBER THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS RACHEL MARTIN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND I WANT TO TALK
TO BUY IT- THE ETHNICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR CAN TERO
CONFIRMATION SINCE THE DAYS OF
OUR FOUNDER WILLIAM PENN MY
JUNIOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION HAS ENJOYED A
VERY CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION AND WE WORK WITH
PARK STAFF AND LEADERSHIP EVERY
DAY TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK SYSTEM.
SINCE TAKING ON HIS CURRENT
ROLE DIRECTOR CAN TERO HAS BEEN
ACCEPTABLE AND COLLABORATIVE
AND HAS DEMONSTRATED A
COMMITMENT TO EXCELLENCE TO
EQUITY AND OVERALL TO THE
IMPORTANT MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT. IN THE NEXT. CHOICE
TO LEAD CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
AT A CRUCIAL MOMENT AND WE ARE
BUSY OPTICALLY IN THE PORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS. MEXICO I
NEVER TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SAM HODDER
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUEAND
STALLIONS OF MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS I WANT TO LEND OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE CONFIRMATION OF
AMONG THE CONTROL TO THE
POSITION OF DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. THE
LEAGUE HAS SHARED NINETY THREE
WONDERFUL YEARS OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
PARTNERSHIP THAT IS
CHARACTERIZED BY A SHARED
RECOGNITION OF THE REDWOOD
FOREST AS AN ICONIC ELEMENT OF
CALIFORNIANS IDENTITY AND
EXPERIENCE. THE GOALS OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BARK. AND AS
AN ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE
AND NOW IS THE PERFECT TIME FOR
A LEADER A LEADER. LIKE ARMAND
OPEN TERO. IT HAD A LONG AND
OUTSTANDING CAREER AND PARKS
AND CONSERVATION INCLUDING HIS
WORK TO ENGAGE TRAIN AND
INSPIRE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
PARK LEADERS. MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE.
INCLUDING AT THE GOLDEN GATE
NATIONAL RECREATION AREA POINT
REYES NATIONAL SEASHORE SEQUOIA
AND KINGS CANYON NATIONAL PARKS
HE'S COMMITTED TO PARTNERSHIPS
AS KEY TO THE STEWARDSHIP OF
OUR TREASURED PARKS. AND THE
BOARD AND STAFF OF SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE LOOK FORWARD TO
ADVANCING OUR PARTNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA'S COAST REDWOOD AND
GIANT SEQUOIA IS PARKS
CALIFORNIA'S REDWOOD PARKS.
WILL PLACE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE COMING YEARS AND OUR MONDO
CAN TERO IS WELL PREPARED TO
HELP SERVE THE NEXT GENERATION.
OF PARK VISITORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS MISTER ROGER RAIDER. IN
THE NEXT COMING COMPLAIN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS NEIL DESAI
WITH THE NATIONAL PARKS
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR BOARD OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE OFFER OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR OUR MONDO QUINN
TERO- THAT'S COMPOUND CONFIRMED
AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
DIRECTOR. AND WE THINK OUR
MONDO FOR HIS DISTINGUISHED
CAREER HAVE LONG STANDING
SERVICE WORK NATION'S PUBLIC HI
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BOTH
AT THE- NATIONAL PARK SERVICE
RANGER IN AND WORKING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA-
SYSTEM AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ALL THE GOOD THINGS WILL COME
TO CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF
HIS. OPPOSITION AT THE STATE
PARKS DIRECTOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE.
THERE OTHER WITNESSES MISTER
MODERATOR. NOPE THE THEIR LOS
OTHER AND CUTEST. OKAY THANK
YOU WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY. I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES
THAT MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. FOR
THE RECORD I WILL KNOW THERE IS
STILL NO ONE PRESENT IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FROM THE
PUBLIC OUGHT TO SPEAK. IT LOOKS
AS IF THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- WAITING TO SPEAK SO
MISTER MODERATOR I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU ALREADY. TO SEE IF
YOU HAVEANYONE ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY COMING UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HELPING US OUT
TODAY WE SO APPRECIATE IT. AND
WITH THAT I HAVE A FEELING THAT
SENATOR LAYERED MAY HAVE OUR
MOTION UNLESS MEMBERS HAVE
OTHER COMMENTS. I THINK I WOULD
MOVE THIS CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE HI I KAMLAGER I
LOVE HER I LOVE HER HI I BATES
HI I ACTON FIVE CONCERNED
GRADUATIONS DIRECTOR WE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST YOUR
SUCCESS IS OUR SUCCESS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH VERY
WELCOME HAVE A GREAT DAY. WITH
THAT TO MY COLLEAGUES- THIS
CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC PORTION OF
TODAY'S AGENDA I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE COOPERATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW GO
INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.